oh hi hi okay so I'm gonna begin my
presentation now
uh so um I guess I'm going to talk about
um
uh genome analysis or Human Genome
analysis and I'm going to talk about um
uh understanding and annotating uh
promoters uh with statistical models and
uh just a one taking a little bit about
me so I I'm a buyer petition I do
computational analysis so I'll make Yale
University and if people want they can
download the slides from the link on the
uh first slide
so now I'm going to go to the second
slide
uh where I will talk about how we think
about uh genome annotation
um and the way I like to think about how
we um might annotate the genome is to
sort of think about how we
um where the word annotation comes from
and how we um annotate other things
besides genomes in particular uh text so
um annotate really refers to uh creating
kind of footnotes and side notes about a
piece of text that describes the what
the function of that text what it's
doing and provides additional
information about it and so I extracted
a little bit of text here to kind of
show you what I mean and this is
actually selected out on compute
programming something I like to do from
this um magazine called American
scientists and so you see the beginning
of an article and you can see in the
article what I've done is I've kind of
um uh called out
bits of the text with colors so for
instance the title is color the first
paragraph there's a quote block quote
and so forth and the the color describes
the uh the function of the text
obviously the different pieces of the
text mean different things so there's
one piece of text for instance is um
describes what this is about and other
describes who wrote it another
introduces it another is kind of um
supporting illustration and so forth and
so you know one bit of annotating is
kind of almost is sort of highlighting
things with different colors and um
essentially creating kind of functional
annotation for it now another type of
things a thing people do when they
annotate text is they look for how
similar a given text is to another text
or how it is how similar it is within a
particular text and so for instance
um in this text the word programmer is
repeated many times so I've kind of
highlighted that and it's kind of
repeated uh word or light Motif and you
know often I find um a bit uh in one
text that's directly quoted or
directly refers to another bit of text
and so often um uh textual annotators
will will highlight these bits and put
footnotes or some sort of reference and
that's another type of text and that's
really type of annotation through
looking at textual similarity so now
we're going to come to the process of um
genome annotation and we really want to
um think of it the same way it's the
same type of process and so on one hand
we can
um
um annotate GMS through comparative
genomics taking the uh the human genome
uh and comparing it uh to to itself
um take or taking the human genome and
comparing it to
um related humans or even to a more
distant organisms such as the mouse and
when we make these comparisons we find
various uh blocks that are um very
similar between things that are very
conserved or blocks that repeated at
different scales and so forth and those
form one type of annotation the other
type of annotation of course is a
functional annotation and here what
happens is someone does a high
throughput experiment they used to be
for instance say array basic premise now
everything is next Generation sequencing
where one gets to read out across the
entire apology number of kind of a
functional signal and usually this
readout is a very noisy signal that the
sort of computer analyst will take and
smooth it and then they'll essentially
call it or threshold it to find various
annotation blocks and these annotation
blocks then of course relate to what
that underlying signal meant and for
instance the signal might describe how
it's the genome are transcribed under
certain conditions or they might
describe how various bits The genome are
bound to or how they're modified and you
know so those functional signals and
functional blocks from them become
become a form of genome annotation so
those are the two basic forms
and then the next thing I'll I'll say
about genome annotation is that
um just how how this is carried out and
you know the human genome and genomics
in general is fairly well known for
being a a very big data discipline but
also a big people discipline this is
really uh historically been carried out
by large groups of people uh working
together
um on things and this is really related
to the original human genomes genome
sequencing around
um the door of the Millennium around
2000 and then when people came to
annotate the genome they uh created a
big group of annotators this is the
well-known encode Consortium of which
I'm part of that's really worked on
annotating the genome so I'm going to
talk to you about um products of that
Consortium today and the Consortium had
some initial pilot projects and uh you
know ending in 2007 on about one percent
of the genome and then 2010 on some
model organism genomes and then in the
last few years it's had a kind of more
production uh rollout on the phone
genome and most recently a kind of
comparable out comparing the um an
updated version of human genome to
um uh the genomes of hormone flying so
I'm going to tell you about some results
kind of from that
so first of all I want to tell you about
the Data Corpus that I'm going to be
looking at and I'm not really going to
talk at all about the tremendous amount
of effort that went into generating's
Data or exactly how the data is
generated because it's really quite a
substantive effort that I'm not going to
give Justice to in that short amount of
time I'm going to present but I'm going
to basically say it's a really large
amount of data that's been
um
sort of collected in a very organized
and uniform way so that one can really
slice through it and analyze it very
systematically and so the data set
basically is a data set looking at many
cell lines associated with the human
genome
um mostly looking at human adults but
also looking at embryonic stem cells and
there's a lot of data collected both on
the transcriptome the readout of the
genome but also regulums what factors
are binding through chipseek experiments
and also how the um uh sort of histones
are modified in various chromata
experiments so I'm going to talk about
that and then there's also kind of
matching or as best match as possible
data sets for these two model
Renaissance worm and fly and these data
sets are some of them are collected on
Cell lines but most importantly they're
also collected on the tissue of the
organism and through the its time course
of development so one can watch the um
development of a woman fraud from an
embryo all the way to an adult and until
the the data says very large the whole
thing I'm talking about it's well over a
billion 100 billion reads and comprising
more than a thousand different uh
replicated data sets and just looking at
the um rna-seq section which I focus on
a bit if that in itself is about 65
billion reads and um a little shy of 600
distinct data sets
so I'm moving on to uh slide six and I
want to sort of talk to you a little bit
about the kind of goals of the kind of
comparative uh part of this analysis and
how one wants to do a kind of functional
analysis and a comparative analysis at
the same time so um you know when one
thinks about uh doing a compare analysis
one of course thinks about how related
the different organisms are there are
things that are fairly close like human
to Mouse things that are much more
distant like human worms and flies and
so forth and so people in the past have
compared fairly closely related
organisms uh say human and mouse in
terms of their um say transcriptomic
data or in terms of one functional
genomics data set or moving on to the
next
um slide they've looked at kind of more
integrated types of things putting many
different types of functional data
together for an individual organism now
this of course was previously done by
end code for human also flying worm
people have done this for yeast
independently they've also done it for
males and what I'm going to Endeavor to
talk a little bit about today is kind of
to do both like very distant comparisons
between say human worm and fly but also
to do those comparisons uh in an
integrated way looking at many of the
different types of functional readouts
the transcriptome the um sort of
regulums looking at The Binding data and
the
readout data
so now moving on to
um slide nine the first thing that
people have looked at
um here is you know how different
um the you know the genes are in these
uh different genomes and they've
compared um the genes and these things
and this picture shows just uh sort of
how many genes are in the different
organisms uh over time for like the past
10 years and the important thing you see
in the picture is
um very flat uh flat lines and so the
The annotation of the genes and the
genome has become fairly stable now
there's still a lot of work to be done
in terms of getting their exact um
splicing structure so forth worked out
but you know the overall number of genes
in the human genome has been fairly
steady the number and the worm genome
has been fairly steady and the number uh
in the fly genome is fairly steady for
the last uh 10 years and you know when
people look at the gene statistics you
know on a very aggregate level they see
you know a lot of the genes in these
organisms do look fairly uh similar you
know they're the size of the exons are
fairly similar when you look at the
distributions the um longest open
reading frame per genes fairly similar
human genes tend to be a little bit
longer than uh until June 10 than the
other ones and that's
um
often because of the number of exons per
Gene and also because of the of course
the size of their introns
so of course the really interesting
thing when um looking at the compare the
comparative genomics and also the
functional genomics is not so much
really looking at the um uh genes in the
genome but um looking at
um the non-coding regions of the genome
where people really know less about them
um and there's really a sense much more
to do and I like to kind of introduce
these on non-coding regions by sort of
talking about them as the dark matter of
the genome and making comparison to the
um dark matter that we see in general in
the universe so
the picture of the slide shows the
actual picture of dark matter so that's
a picture through a telescope of dark
matter and what you see when you look at
dark matter is you know you don't see it
you see just the stars but the way
astronomers uh see uh the dark matter is
they see it by the way it affects the
light coming from the Stars it
essentially lenses that Starlight or it
regulates it bends it and and that's I
think a very good analogy to the um dark
matter of the genome
um a lot of the darkness of the genome
what it does is it less it it modulates
the effect of the genes it it's involved
in the regulation of the genes when they
go on and off how much they're
transcribed how they work and so forth
and so I think that's the kind of
picture we're going to be talking about
today we're going to talk a lot about
Gene regulation I think dark matter of
regime is also importantly so a lot of
the Disease Association people are
finding more and more is really in
relation to the these um non-coding
regions of the genome
so moving on to slide 12 what I'm going
to talk about today is um focusing on
one particular
um part of the Dark Knight of the gym
that's really the part that sits right
Upstream of the Gene and that's the
promoter of the uh the the Gene and one
of the the key aspects of these um
uh promoters is um are they active and
and uh the activity of the promoter is
often described by kind of how open it
is and so you can have you have the um
DNA Upstream the gene it's often uh
wound around these uh histones and when
the gene becomes very active it becomes
kind of very open and when it comes very
repressed it's very uh closed down so
some key annotation questions that we
are going to uh sort of talk about are
you know how do we Define these where
the actual promoter annotation is and
then when we have an active promoter how
do we talk about
um its degree of activity in terms of
how many transcription factors are
bounds or what the chromatin looks
around that or it's epigenetic marks and
how we relate this to uh transcription
and then we wanted to talk about how
conserve these um uh kind of ideas and
principles are amongst different
organisms so they very similar are they
very
um different do they represent very
fundamental things are very young
specific things so moving on to slide 13
the the answers to these questions I'm
going to talk about I think they're kind
of significant because
um on one hand they um
uh sort of tell us about kind of very
conserved in ancient principles of gene
expression in animals of course they're
also very useful in helping us better
annotate and understand what each base
in the genome is actually doing and then
in particular in relation to sort of
epigenetic changes and so forth I think
the very important uh some diseases
because you know for instance in cancer
we often see a lot of global epigenetic
changes in the genome and what we really
want to know is how those changes are
coupled to new genes being turned on or
turned off and so forth and so so the
the what we're going to talk about today
is going to be related to that so now
moving on to slide 14.
um
what I'm going to talk about as I've
shown in this little mini outline so the
first thing I talked about was kind of a
little introduction to genome annotation
and the encode and the data we're going
to look at and so then I'm going to
focus on two things in the rest of the
talk I'm going to first talk about how
we relate the histo marks uh Upstream of
the gene to the gene expression and you
know how it works kind of how to develop
a kind of a very general model for this
and then I'm going to talk a little bit
about how we relate the transcription
factors um that are binding up between
Gene to its expression compare them to
the histone marks and one surprising
things we're going to find is that very
few transcription factors I think are
actually uh surprisingly very few
transmission factors can get very
successful uh prediction of the output
of a gene
and so those are the two topics that
we're going to cover in detail so now
going to slide 15. let me give you a
just a little schematic of this this the
the problem that the way we're going to
pose the problem uh so the picture shows
uh two sort of a horizontal uh dark
lines and they represent the genome in
two different cell types and so two
different bits of activity and the you
can see there's genes on the genome and
the level of expression genes is kind of
explained by the little green
um the little green thing so how much
how on and off certain genes are and
then the promoter directly Upstream is a
little blue line that um and the the
activity of the promoter in terms of how
many things are bound to it or how it's
the um how much the degree of its
histone modifications is indicated by
the amount of the red things and so what
we want to basically do is we want to
make a plot where we plot the amount of
the red lines for each um Gene to the
number of green lines and so we would do
that over saying that twenty thousand
genes in the image you know and then we
have a plot such as the one uh shown on
the bottom where we relate expression to
some measure of motor activity and you
know ideally we'd want them to be
correlated so that we can almost
um predict or relay the promoter
activity to the expression level and now
we can do this actually for more than
one cell on these I think one of the key
ideas is that in different types of
cells
the because of the different epigenetics
the certain promoters are going to
become active and others not and we want
to look at the kind of changing
epigenetics and and think about how that
is going to be related to um the
changing chain expression and so that's
the overall cartoon picture and that
little XY plot shows the kind of cartoon
so let me start to show what it looks
like with real data so on 5 16 I showed
just a very basic picture where we just
look at say one histo mark That's
hbk4me3 and another thing that's very
The Binding of a factor that's very
Associated transcription polymerase what
does it actually look like so on the we
I'm showing this actually uh for data
from the worm this is just a
representative plot and on the um y-axis
you see the kind of input you know the
the histo Mark or the polymerase binding
and on the x-axis you see the output the
expression and you can see a kind of
rough correlation and let's just focus
on the um
uh numbers roughly you see about a 0.6
um sort of Spearman number for for both
of those uh correlations yes they're
each of those
um uh sort of inputs are roughly
correlated with the output but not
perfectly correlated I mean 0.6 isn't
isn't perfectly correlated and so what
we want to do is see if we can do better
and see if that gives us some further
understanding and so that's what I'm
going to talk balance line 17. we tried
to make a more sophisticated
mathematical model of this process so
what we did is we looked around the TSS
the start of um
transcription the Gene and we made
little bins up right up in front of it
and right after it and and also the same
at the end of the Gene and then in each
of these bins we put in each of them the
amount of the um the particular
chromatin features the histone
modifications or we as I'll tell you
later we did the same thing for
transcription factors and then we also
put the correlation of this one
um modification with the gene expression
level across all the genes okay so now
we have all these different bins with
their different correlations and now
what we're going to try to do is relate
that those correlations to the um
uh gene expression level of the gene
from the rnac that's the overall set of
the concept experiment and then in slide
18 the next slide you can start to see a
little bit of how the data looks so now
looking at the right hand side of the
slide you see this sort of heat map
where you have we have many different
histo marks and this is a very simple
heat map for a model organism this is
for worm where you see for each of the
bins the degree to which that bin has a
correlation with gene expression and you
can see that there's the red represents
more correlation blue represents the
sort of anti-correlation so you can see
some marks like hdk9 me2 are repressive
marks they're anti-correlated some marks
are like h3k4 and me2 are are red
they're positive and the correlation
really depends on the position here
sometimes the correlation is much
stronger close to TSS
um which weaker farther from the TSS so
now what we're going to do is put all
these things together into a um
mathematical model
and that's what's shown on Slide 19. and
so we're going to put them together into
two mathematical models so first
mathematical model we're going to make
is just simply a classification model
and we're going to use this particular
uh type of um class of article to
support Vector machine I'm not going to
describe in detail but basically it puts
a lot of the different uh the
correlations from a lot of the different
marks together and what we try to do is
to classify genes to highly Express
versus slowly expressed and now the
first thing we can do is we can see how
we do and that's shown if this What's
called the AUC curve which is shown the
top left hand of the slide and we can
make this AUC curve for all the
different bins Upstream of the TSS and
you can see some bins get a a better AUC
there's more area above the curve and
some less
a lesser ABC and so we can plot then on
the bottom left-hand figure
the overall score for each of the bins
and so we can see which the bins in
front of the TSS is most predictive and
as you might expect the bins right
around the TSS contribute most to the
prediction and um and whereas those more
distant contribute less so the next
thing we can do is we can move from
doing a classification model to doing
what's called a regression model where
we try to directly predict the overall
level of expression Gene through putting
together all the different marks and so
I show
that on the top right hand side and so
you can see this is for a model organism
you have the observed expression versus
the predicted expression for 13
different histogram arcs integrating
them now with this mathematical
technique called support Vector
regression and you can see we get a
pretty good outline there's a good R
here it's about R of about 0.75 this is
pure sin correlation and then in
addition what we can do is we can take
our model that we've parameterized
trained and tested on protein coding
genes and we can apply that model
without modification to
um the promoters of non-coding
um rnas nuclear micrornas and actually
we get some correlation there which is
also quite impressive since we never
really parametrized them all against
them but it's being used to predict um
on the basis of them
okay so now let's go to the next slide
slide 20. so now what we can uh do is we
can uh we have the epigenetics and we
have the um uh rnac readout from many
different types of cells and for
instance in numeral have many cell lines
in the um uh worm in the fly will have
many different developmental stages and
so we can play this game where we say oh
well how well does the um epigenetics
and say one particular stage predict the
expression in that stage or the
expression in another station now
naively you'd expect and correctly that
if you match the stages you would get
the best prediction and lo and behold
that's what we see so for instance these
two classification of the classification
Curves in the graphs show the prediction
of the embryo gene expression level from
the embryo epigenetics which is the blue
line and then the other lines are shown
based on other stages the larval stage
the epigenetics and those and you see
you a lot worse and so this of course
shows that it gives you a measure of how
the um matched the epigenetics are to
the actual readout and expression you
get in a particular stage
um okay now moving on to uh slide 21. so
now I'm going to move from model
organism kind of up which is more of a
simple setup to um uh um to human and
I'm going to show you the results this
is from the enco construction paper a
while ago so best we could do on human
and this was it's a little complicated
how this thing was kind of sort of set
with all the classification and a
regression model but the bottom line is
when you when you put all the points
there for uh you know all the the genes
down you can do really well you the
measure expression is shown on the Y and
the objective expression is shown the X
and the overall R you get is about 0.9
which is a very very good prediction and
especially as far as bioinforming
predictions go this is quite a good
prediction and in addition you get for
each in the model you get a sense of how
important each of the individual histone
marks are in the model and that's what's
shown on the bar graph on the bottom
left
and I'm going to come back to the
relative importance of these histone
marks in in a second
um so then the next uh thing we can do
is we can do the same thing with the
same model and kind of compare many
different um organisms and so here I
show just trying to build a model for
worm trying to build a fly trying to
build for human you know for yeast build
it for Mouse and the bottom is you can
do relatively well in all the organisms
if you build them all you can see they
look slightly different the r's are
slightly different but overall you you
seem to be able to do this kind of
predict expression from the histo marks
fairly consistently in on all the um
many in human to many organisms and so
that brings us to the idea of maybe we
can actually
um compare the models that we build and
even go farther and try to build some
sort of um
Universal model that work across many
organisms that really represents some
basic and ancient features or
transcription and so that's what I'm
trying to do in slide 23. so here what
you see is you see those little pictures
that describe the um
correlations with gene expression for
all the different histo marks Upstream
of the TSS
for three different organisms human fine
worm and the um human is kind of reddish
the worm is kind of greenish and the
Flies bluish and you can see the
patterning is fairly similar but it's
not exactly the same for the human
flying Worm for all the different marks
but not not exactly the same and then
what we can do is we can build a model
for each of them and
um and those and then we can look at the
relative importance of each of the marks
in that model so for instance the
importance of the marks in human are
shown by that very big red bar to the
top right and then the importance of the
marks for were Michonne and by the green
bar implied the blue bar and what you
can see is the different marks have
different importance in the model for
instance in human
h3k4me3 is actually quite important
whereas in uh worm and fly it's less
important and so forth and that seems to
vary and that may be a reflects in the
fact that Newman
um you know there's really a different
scale to the Upstream region than in in
worm and fly and so then what we can do
is we can actually imagine if we take
the structurally half of the models we
can imagine to try to combine the models
into simultaneously build a model that
would work without change on all three
organisms human warm and Phi we call
this a universal odd model
and the importance of each of the marks
in that Universal model is shown by the
black bar in the right hand side figure
with the word Universal over it and so
you can see in that particular model
h3k4 me2 uh and h3k4me3 which are very
well known for more marks are the most
predictive or the most important marks
and the model and something like
um uh the
um the h3k27 acceleration becomes less
important whereas in say the human model
it was more more important
and so it's interesting to see these
differences in which uh which marks are
kind of the most ancient and the most um
have I dropped off my online
foreign
I hope I'm still online I my screen uh
yeah okay thank you my screen just blank
for a second and I was very worried that
I had uh dropped off
um in any case we were on slide 23 and I
was talking about the relative
importance in the uh in the
um different organisms of the different
marks and talking about this Universal
model and then the neat thing is we can
take the universal model and we can see
how well that model does in um uh
predicting relative to organism specific
models and so that's what we did and the
uh the Grid on the top right hand side
we look we look at developing a model
saying human and predicting on human
developing a model and say human and
applying that molecule worm developing
them all in human applying it to fly and
in those contexts you can see the r that
you get and the human obviously if you
build them all in human you predict on
human you're going to do much better
than if you
um try to transfer that model directly
to worm and fly and like I should throw
them all on worm you'll do better and so
forth but what's really neat is if you
look at the um bottom part of the right
hand thing you can see the prediction
accuracy of this Universal model and so
the universal model does almost exactly
well as the organism specific model so
for instance in human organs and
specific model gets an R 0.82 whereas
the universal model will get a 0.8 and
in fly it will get 0.84 the universal
model will get 0.83 and so that's really
quite impressive it says I can develop a
set of parameters for model that work
equally well and even more and fly as
developing a model in that organism
specifically and it says that we can
really talk about the relationship
between
um the Upstream chromatin structure and
the level of gene expression in a very
basic and fundamental way and then the
other thing we can do which is
particularly means we can take our model
as we did for the organ specific models
and we can apply that model which is
parametrized across across all the
organisms on protein coding genes but
now we can apply it to non-coding rnas
and lo and behold the model actually is
very successful for instance in human it
gets almost 0.7
accuracy in predicting non-coin rnas and
worm it doesn't do as well but I think
that's because of the Fairly poor TSS
definitions in that organism
okay so now we've finished uh talking
about
um uh the histomark models and I'm going
to move on to the TF model so I'm moving
through my outline slide to now slide
26. and so now we're going to do the
same game that we just did for histone
marks but we're going to do it for
transcription factors and so so for
instance at the top you see I'm just
doing a showing a representative picture
where I have a number of worms
transcription factors I have bins
Upstream of the TSS as I did for histone
marks and I'm correlating The Binding of
those things with the gene expression
red is high blue is low the neat thing
you can see here is there's a real kind
of bipartite structure to the fit to the
figure there's activators that are
highly correlated with gene expression
and then there are repressors that are
natively quality of gene expression and
likewise there's some factors such as
elt3 where they seem to have all their
correlation right Upstream of the
promoter and other factors such as CA
ceh 14 team which seemed to be more like
histo Marx where they seem to be uh to
sort of have activity over the entire um
promoter and then more directly in the
bottom part of the figure I then compare
um the TFS between different um
different organisms you know between the
human which is the red shade the um the
worm and the Fly you're just looking at
the um
different patterns so then in slide 27
we do the same thing we try to build a
model uh to predict the gene expression
now this is a little bit more
complicated model it's a sort of a
multi-layer model where first what we do
is we integrate all the information the
correlations in one bin using the
support of vector regression for say one
bin we do that for all the bins Upstream
the TSS and now we have another layer of
our model that takes the output of all
those uh support Vector regressions and
puts that into one one model we make a
combined prediction and then we compare
that to the um gene expression level or
it's the rna-seq
and how well do we do so here's the
results we have for human now remember
for human we could get about
um uh 0.9 the best that's what we could
get with the joint classification
regression model here we get 0.81 which
is good but it's not as good but it's
pretty good and it starts using the
predictions of the TFS and of course
here what we can do is rank many of the
TFS by their relative
importance in the model and we can see
some TFS for instance
yy1 has a you know more has a greater
predictive power than others
uh the other thing we can do is in
addition to predicting the gene
expression of a gene we can also predict
its differential expression if we have
the gene expression in two different uh
cell lines we can look at the difference
in expression and if we have the
epigenetics in those same two solids we
can look at the difference the change
the Delta epigenetics between the uh the
two cell lines or the differential TF uh
binding between the two cell lines and
we can find that the um differential TF
binding you know how much the TF binding
changes is actually uh fairly predictive
of the gene expression not as predictive
as the absolute but but fairly
predictive and that's what's shown in
the heat map
um in slide 29
and then in 5 30 the other thing we can
do is we can look at the relative
importance of the TFS in different cell
lines for instance one cell line is k562
another is gm12878 and what's
interesting is that some TFS are more
important in some cell lines than others
so for instance
um in k562 yy1 is particularly important
and sp1 is very important in other cell
lines uh different TFS become very
important for instance resp
and elf one are very important in
gm12878 and that's sort of associated
with the transcription factors that we
know to be very important in those
particular lineages for instance elf one
we know to be very important in the
white blood cell lineage
then the other thing we can do on slide
31 is we can compare the histomark
models and the transcription Factor
model the the TF models and um here uh
what we can see is uh we can look at the
relative importance of each of the bins
Upstream the TS Upstream the TSS and you
can see that the TF mom the top right
hand side it's much more peaked the
overall the region right around the TSS
is much more important in that model
than histone Mark model where it's it's
more diffuse and also the area around
over the gene body is is is very
important so you can see the the sort of
differences between the TFS and the um
histo marks and then the other thing you
can do in these pictures is you could
say well we have a um TF model and we
have a histone more model why don't we
combine them and make a super uber model
that has all of the things and maybe
we'll be able to do even better and so
we did that and that's shown in the
black line in the bottom right hand side
of the figure and that now interesting
enough that black line doesn't do any
better than the histo mark model so what
that implies is there's no extra
information in the TF binding that's not
that's not encoded in the histone
modifications it's in his insofar as
prediction is is the case which is kind
of an interesting thing so all of the
information about the gene expression
that we can get lies within those
histone modifications there's no extra
information that we can get from the
transcription Factor binding
not completely intuitive but it is the
case
um the other thing we can do is we can
look at the um the sort of peakedness of
the TF model uh versus the histone model
in different um organisms and here we
compare that um in human world fly the
red green and blue uh figures in
relation to genes uh non-chlorine rnas
uh and um and you know what we basically
see is that that same pattern is
observed across all the different
organisms as we observed in a particular
organism
and then the final thing we can do which
is kind of neat and slide 33 is we can
say well how many transcription factors
do we need to make a successful
prediction so we can take say let's say
we take of the almost thousand
transcription factors in human we take
five we randomly pick five and now we
need experiments more and done on a
thousand exponents are only done on
maybe up to 200 now we pick a subset of
five and we can take many different
subsets of five and we can see how well
we do and now we can do subsets we can
do subsets of six subsets of seven and
so for them we can for any given number
for instance 5 we can average the
results we'll get from all the different
picks and that's what you see on the red
curve and what it shows which is quite
remarkable is that one can actually get
a very good uh predictive uh performance
almost as good as a full model with all
the available TFS with only a small set
of TFS so if one only uses five
transcription factors just a random
selection 5 one gets 90 percent of the
predictive power of a model with 30 or
or 40 TFS and that's not completely
um intuitive you might say well there's
a thousand TFS there's each of them has
great specificity for
um a sort of gene expression why is it
that we're so successful predicting with
only a small number of transcription
factors where is the specificity where's
the information in the other uh
transmission factors and and when we
first presented this result years ago
people found it very um
uh paradoxical at that that it could be
the case but um I can rationalize this
actually I can give you a biological
rationalization I can also say that
we've repeated this type of thing in
many different contexts and many
different organisms for instance in warm
and fly you get a very similar pattern
uh shown by the blue and the green lines
now the biological rationalization for
this is that we're we're
measuring here steady state levels of
gene expression after the chromatin has
been opened and what imagines after the
chromatin has been opened one has some
transcription factors that are bound may
be opportunistically maybe not even
specifically that are more a proxy for
how much the chromatin has been opened
so the more the chromoses opened you get
more kind of low level opportunistic
binding of the transcription factors and
this opportunistic binding doesn't
reflect as much the specificity of
actually opening up the chromatin
dynamically and setting up the initial
gene expression this this being done by
some Pioneer transcription factors that
come in open up the chromatin that's not
at all shown by these correlations and
what you're seeing here is more
um the so steady state level of gene
expression and how the TFS really are
just mirroring back the results of the
chromatin being opened
uh the other thing we can do uh with the
transcript factors I'll briefly just say
is um we can take them and we can
arrange them into our transcription
Factor Network I'm not going to describe
this in detail this is uh uh described
in other words and it turns out in this
network we can build a bit of a
hierarchy with some other factors sit at
higher levels than others and I won't
describe how that this is built but
other than to show you a selection of
roughly 120 of the human transmission
factors create this three level
hierarchy that you see in the top left
hand side of the figure what's kind of
neat is we can look at each of the
factors in the hierarchy and calculate
its um overall power in the model in
terms of driving a gene expression and
we can color each of the factors by its
overall power and that's shown by the
blue tinge to each of the factors in
slide 35. and what you can see is kind
of neat is that the factors on the
higher levels of this hierarchy uh tend
to have um slightly stronger correlation
or slightly stronger power in the model
to drive gene expression uh sort of the
idea being that they're more a higher up
you sit in the hierarchy the more
influential you are in terms of odd
driving gene expression so now moving to
slide 36 I just like to summarize my
talk so today I talked to you about some
Distributing genomes analysis in
particular I talked to you a lot about
uh really looking at promoters with uh
statistical models and so first I
introduced how we do the uh genome
annotation and particularly I introduced
the large Corpus of um data from the
encode project that we looked at the
large amount of human data loss of data
on model organisms and then I focused on
kind of two slices of the data
connecting essentially the inputs the
histo modifications and the
transcription factors to the outputs the
rna-seq so first we build a histone
model of gene expression and some of the
key things from a model is it works
pretty well and it actually works for
non-quiring rnas as well as genes it's
fairly tissue specific and what I think
is kind of neat and not completely
intuitive is we can actually build this
uh Universal mod one set of parameters
that works on everything works on
protein chlorine genes non-fouring rnas
Works across organisms and so forth
and then I talked about building
transcription Factor models and I think
the key take comes from this so that you
can see here that you get the different
importance of the different bins in
front of the um TSS in terms of the
importance of the model and here you can
see how the TFS are the reason right in
front of the TSS is much more important
for the transcription factors than
histone modifications and this is very
important in terms of defining the
actual promoter of the real important
regulatory region and then um also you
find though that in terms of statistical
models the signals we get from
transcription Factor models and
histomark models are very redundant
there's no additional information in the
TF models they're really just mirroring
back the information in the open
chromatin and histone Mark models and um
surprisingly because because of this we
get the surprising conclusion that
actually only a small number of TFS are
quite
um predictive of gene expression you can
achieve the predictive power of a full
model with only about a five
transcription factors which is quite um
not intuitive but I tried to rationalize
biologically and then in slide 37 and 38
I'm going to acknowledge things I like I
said this is uh all this work is part of
this uh bigger encode amount encode
Consortium there's lots of people
involved in in this in this particular
slide here
um uh 37 I show all the people involved
in What's called the mod end code encode
transcriptom group these are all the
people that really focused on the
transcription uh in which we built these
models and I didn't even talk um in in
the presentation much about the
large-scale data generation but a lot of
the people in this group of course are
generating all these huge and wonderful
data sets in particular we need to
acknowledge uh Bob what are some times
in jars and soon selniker who led the um
day-to-generation efforts on um worm
human and fly respectively and also
greatly uh participated in this uh very
much and then the other people listed on
this figure uh a lot of the analysts and
I kind of highlighted some of the key
analysts uh who worked on this uh Joe
rozovski Chow Chang Kunk Yan and so
forth now the person who really was the
key analyst for the specific stuff that
I talked about today is a Chao uh Chang
and so if we move to slide
um 38 I actually have a more specific
acknowledgments for chow because he
developed a lot of these the statistical
Machinery in um separate uh sort of
smaller scale separate works and then
applied it to the big Consortium and so
Chao was a um post talk with me for many
years he's now moved on to a a
faculty position at Dartmouth and he
worked very excessively with uh
barge Raj and uh Grand Quin Min uh and
others and also as you ping Wang it at
bu in developing these models and with
that I'd like to end I'd like to get a
final note also say that I'm Keen to um
recruit additional new postdocs talent
to people like uh ciao for my lab and
there's a URL for that on the slide and
thank you very much for your attention
uh some other
uh
oh there are questions uh oh I see okay
I click on sorry I'm learning about this
I click on the Q a here okay so I see
now
um so the first question is how might we
use a human text to treat cancer uh well
that's a that's a good um a good
question that's how I introduce the talk
and I think that it's obviously we're
not gonna
um literally do that but I think a lot
of the the the Machinery that we
developed to annotate uh human texts and
the approaches that we use to do text
Mining and the ideas we have there's
some transferability to how we can use
that to annotate The genome and
annotating genome I think is very
important in terms of uh treating cancer
because uh cancer is a disease of a
truly messed up genome you know our
genome gets really messed up we have
cancer it gets rearranged uh the
epigenetic changes uh uh change over so
I think the the one can transfer a lot
of the mathematical ideas and I think
that's quite useful
uh now let's see so the um next uh
question was uh
how do we uh control the active regions
promoters
um well I I talked a little bit about
that in the um
uh talk you know really when the you
know how the promoter becomes active
when the chromatin is open from the
histone modifications and then I talked
a bit about
um the um uh you know also the
transmission factor is binding and you
know what activity we see in the
promoter regions and and how we relate
that to gene expression so now moving on
to the next question see more see direct
relationship to rocket ship model
this was a bizarre question so I think
we're going to read this one so then the
next one was have you formed these
models with cell specific data if yes
what you mean uh can you see more
information coming from specific
instruments or from TFS as a group so
yes now all these uh models are based on
Cell specific data so one takes a given
type of cell or a cell line and one
collects an rnac data set and many
different Gypsy gases the Gypsy test
that's coming from transcription factors
that are binding in that cell line or
um histone modifications in that
particular cell line and they have to
and they have to be very cell line
matched because I think as I showed you
in the earlier presentation if we take
the histone modifications or
transcription factors from a different
cell line they're much less predictive
of gene expression than in the match
cell and that makes a lot of sense
because that's really how the
epigenetics exerts its effect by
um it changes and that turns the genes
on and off and so forth uh then there's
a another question number six here can
the data generated from these studies be
used to assess uh active promoter
regions for targeted genes and possibly
correlate with the effect of snips in
those active regions yes most assuredly
that's I didn't talk about that but
that's what we're quite actively working
on and so the whole point is if you can
use these bins to figure out which of
the regions the promoters are really
important
um and you know where the epigenetic uh
changes in the transcription Factor
binding really affects things you
obviously know where the regions that
are more sensitive to the um uh sequence
variations the Snips and the structural
variants are
um
and uh we you know eventually we hope to
be able to really understand if a given
uh snip or even more to the point to
somatic alteration that you might have
in cancer will exert effect on
transcription in the promoter
um now let's see uh question seven was
how many features were selected for
classification and regression analysis
so that's a very good question
um now we I talked to you about a lot of
uh different analyzes we've done frankly
over a number of years and and you know
the analyzes aren't exactly matched I
mean some we used uh certain group of
factors others uh a different group of
histor marks but let me just give you a
a good sort of a way to think about this
is if you go back to slide let me see if
I can quickly uh find that slide if we
go back to slide 28 there's our human
um all the human factors that we looked
at and that basically shows you have
about 25 factors in a Cell line that
we're building a model on 30 factors
maybe maybe more maybe uh 50 but that's
the number we're using for a lot of
these models and then for instance in
slide 23 we show the key marks that we
used that were kind of in every organism
we use maybe 7 70 marks we use to make
these uh histone Mark models
okay then moving on to question eight uh
the question was uh thanks for your talk
you've mentioned about developing cross
species model How Far We've added for TF
from various prokaryotic organism or is
only for eukaryotes so first of all all
of this is only valid for eukaryotes I
mean a lot of this um uh the chromatin
discussion and really all this is really
a eukaryotic discussion we've never
thought about applying it for propriet I
mean potentially for the transcription
Factor some of it might be transferable
we've never done that
um now we've not really developed trans
um Universal cross-species models for
the TFS and that's because we don't have
enough true ortholog data sets for the
TS now for the histo markets we have the
same histo Mark like hbk4 me3 being
collected many different organ systems
for TS you know we have polymerase of
many organisms but we don't have many
other TFS we have the same tfma orgasm
so that will really have to wait uh for
further data sets in the future so
that's question number eight
and then moving on to question number
nine
how did you decide which TFS bind to the
promoted regions if it's purely by
binding sites how do you eliminate the
large amount of false positives since
most binding sites are short uh so
that's a good question
um what we do here it's a little
different was we're we're not we're only
looking at promoter so first of all
we're not looking at The Binding outside
the promoter we're looking at the buying
the priority and we're not per se
calling whether something is bound or
not we just basically have the a
continuous readout signal from the chip
seek experiment it's very it's very
close to the data of just the level of
binding now the level could be very
close to the noise level right it could
be very low very small number it could
be a medium number that maybe reflects
non-specific bonding that just reflects
opportunistic bonding to an open
promoter or it could be a very large
number that reflects very strong and
specific binding all of those numerics
go into the model okay so this very
small numbers the medium numbers and the
large numbers go into the model and
there's less a sense of whether that
Bond I mean whether the binding is
specific and functional or non-specific
and opportunistic we don't differentiate
against but then in a sense do we need
to or do we want to maybe not
um and that's that's the way I would
answer that and so that's um
a question from Queen Yang
um and I'm done with that and then it
says I have no questions available for
display oh hold on how would you oh no
there seems to be one more here number
ten how would you suggest to annotate
snip or other types of genetic mutation
with chromosome modification data so
that's a very good question
um I think the key I I don't I don't
think one would annotate the Snips
themselves with the chromatin
modification did I think a better way of
doing it is to use the permanent
modification data to annotate regions in
the genome and then talk about where the
Snips lie so do do do the does the
chromatin data say we line a promoter
does a chromatin data say rely enhancer
and then is that enhancer promoter
active in a particular cell line and
then if we have the snip there
presumably that snap affects a active
promoter or enhancer in a given type of
cell that's that's the way I would uh
approach that annotation and again we
seem to have no questions for display
so I I think that means I'm done so let
me ask our moderators am I done
oh hold on now it's beeping again
so oh there's a question 11. what are
some of the technical hurdles did you
have to overcome processing the data so
that's a very good question
um now of course I really glossed over
big time the actual data generation and
also a lot of the immediate processing
of data so there's a serious and a
serious amount of technical challenges
uh in actually
um getting the data from the sequencing
machines
um managing the data on your disk but
then also normalizing all the data sets
so all the signals right removing
artifactual regions of the genome
mapping the the um the reads correctly
to genome dealing with um mismapping or
multi-mapping reads and so forth and
getting a very pure and nice
well-normalized signal and those signals
are what then fed into my model so this
is a very um Downstream or derivative
talk in a sense removed from a lot of
the hard and complicated the work that
goes with building these data sets but
of course that's the point of building
these uh wonderful resources like the in
code mod and code resource where all
that work is done and you can use the
processed data
uh so um I have no more questions or I'm
going to thank the audience now uh for
listening uh
um and I think it says I'm I'm being
turned off so take take care
um I guess I say goodbye
uh okay uh is that it uh am I done